[Applaudissements]
sa voisine
et cela
dans son attention
laval énervé jean le cam ward l arbitre
à c'est vous qui allez expliquer les
règles
jean-luc c'est parti alors c'est très
simple avec des épreuves de rapidité
celui qui arrive dernier à une hta nas
d'accord c'est en plusieurs étapes
parce que j'étais la première tana si on
la découvre regarder la première à nas
pour celui qui perdra ses amarres tarte
à la crème de la crème parc mokhtar dans
la gueule exactement
calais premier défi premier défi de
rapidité vous avez devant vous une
banane chacun non ne touchez pas la
banane un bon signal voulait plus hachée
et vous la mangez entièrement attention
1 2 3
et les premiers chassés dont je me dis
c'est bon et moi notre insu j'adore les
bananes j'ai peur de me vendre de la
preuve sonic youth
malgé projet on se rappelle moi vite
dans l'émission est maintenant
[Applaudissements]
seulement
john george et gill a fait des minettes
de ski alors êtes-vous fait un shampoing
totale avec le gel s'appellera cette
fois il va pas et lui et lui même élu
let in usa peut pas seul mais en l'air
il faut que tu le coiffe en l'air ça lui
ira mieux
nous sommes ravis car je vais t'aider un
peu au nom d'un micro pour qui cela mais
tu sais quoi
si tu dois seulement les cheveux ça va
pas marcher pour le coiffe aussi la
barre et les sourcils
attention sans doute eu à perdre tes os
sa création un truc pas de version des
faits selon l'intérieur ah bah oui ça
pue mais c'est vrai de l'info du dedans
[Applaudissements]
à
cyril elle est allée faire du sport
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que il
en fait c'est lebron les mauvaise
haleine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression qu'un truc un peu
chimiques comme arrive et demande aux
gens sur le c2 embarque mickey nous a
quittés c'est fukushima dans ma bouche
aux déboires la voudrait voir vraiment
où le ratio n'est jamais de la vie
[Applaudissements]
alors
c'est pas possible ça pas de bons
ballons et mecha vous savez moi j'étais
volontaire c'est le moment le grand duel
c'est le moment de la grande finale
michaël bercy qui a pu alors presque là
tu utilises ses chroniqueurs pour pas
aller vraiment vraiment au fond des
choses
sapeurs ont séché les doutes sa guise
grave ne pourrait pas nickel le sens on
se couvre les cas c'est parti tout seul
nom n'a pas fini non mais c'est parti
tout seul
on attend le train
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
mais son tarif
[Musique]
à
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
georges
gagné